we're going big-budget here bye honey
I'm gonna celebrate American
independence
[Music]
big day today today is a travel day
took me a long time to realize that I
didn't have to judge myself if my brain
was attacking me it's just showing up
for the meditation you know and once you
notice that to just bring it back to the
president bring it back to the breath
without judging yourself for your mind
wandering off because that's what it
does
so people who think like I can't
meditate my mind just runs too quickly I
can't sit still
that's actually an argument for why you
do need to meditate because you need to
develop mastery over that and some days
I can just drop in and like be totally
present and time fades away and it seems
like 20 minutes goes in at Hingston
today it felt it felt like 40 minutes
so people always ask me how do you eat
when you're on the road when you're
traveling and frankly I think most
people overthink this most domestic
flights are only a couple hours so I
don't need to eat on the airplane in a
pinch I can get bananas and nuts in any
airport and that's perfectly fine to
tide me over for a couple hours if I'm
flying in New York like a five or six
hour flight maybe I'll bring a little
bit more but I'm flying internationally
today even though they'll serve me a
vegan meal on the plane it's probably
not enough food for me and I don't know
exactly what they're gonna give me so I
make my own food to bring on the plane
so today I'm gonna be bringing
sandwiches these are avocado sandwiches
I made five of them
avocado lettuce sprouts mustard a little
bit of so five publicado sandwiches so
they could be more than enough some Peru
cos Peru nuts
courtesy of my friend Darren these are
awesome I always bring bananas wherever
I go and then just some trail mix goji
berries longan fruit walnuts and pine
nuts so two of these and apples so I
think this'll tide me over
when in doubt so I can swing this on the
plane
all right let's hit the road let's do it
Oh bye honey
hold down the house be a good girl so
I've been traveling a ton this is my
second overseas adventure in a month I
love everything about flying people are
like the airports and the hassle and all
of that but I think it's the most
amazing thing that we can do air travel
is the closest thing to time travel that
we have and I get so excited every time
I have an opportunity to get on a plane
and as I was getting ready this morning
and packing up I was reflecting on
2008 when Julie and I were just
absolutely broke we didn't know how we
were gonna make it we were on the
precipice of losing our house we could
couldn't really pay our bills but
somehow we were able to pull together
with the help of friends and family the
budget for me to participate in Ultraman
my first big ultra endurance race and
I'll never forget when Julie took me to
the airport to drop me off for that
experience like we just both liked
hugged on the curb when she dropped me
off and we were like falling like it was
so emotional because I knew and I think
she knew in that moment that on a
symbolic level the fact that I was going
to do this race was setting in motion
something we didn't know what but
something that would ultimately shift
things for us it's this weird crazy
spiritual equation I talked about in my
book that when your heart is true when
your spirit is true that ultimately the
universe will conspire to support you
and that doesn't mean it's gonna be
overnight it doesn't mean it's gonna
look like the way you want it to look
and it's just crazy that 10 years later
I mean it took a decade but that 10
years later Here I am going to Dublin in
London getting paid you know to go it
makes no sense none of it makes logical
sense so what does that mean well I
think it means that if you have a dream
or you have a big goal
that you should go for it life is so
short it's so precious it's so easy to
just fall into our routines and get into
a rut and then we become myopic almost
like we're living finders and we can't
see outside the box that we've created
for ourselves so we're in Venice right
now we just passed the street that I
lived on when I first moved to Los
Angeles Marine Street that's where I
bottomed out on drugs and alcohol it's
like the life I was living was so
different so one of my favorite things
to do before getting on an airplane has
come down to Venice Park at the beach go
for a run jump in the ocean and then
change into what I'm gonna wear on the
plane and then head to the airport like
totally refreshed I get a workout in I
get a little salt water on the skin
because I'm gonna be out of the country
on July 4th
I'm gonna miss Independence Day in
America I'm gonna celebrate American
independence my my stars and stripes and
running shorts
[Music]
all right good run really quick it's so
nice to do that Rhys did you thank you
for arranging for the hair and makeup
trailer we're going big budget here
we got a hair a makeup trailer full
production crane drones the whole thing
it's great to derive inspiration from
Superstars but what's most important is
that you choose the right path the right
goal for you not everybody can be LeBron
James or even Dez Landon who I just had
on the podcast but we all have something
special that makes us uniquely who we
are and I think and believe they feel
strongly that our purpose is to really
express that because we need everybody
to be more of who they really are and
one of the interesting things that came
up in my podcast with Dez which just
went off last night is that despite her
remarkable story career two-time
Olympian incredible marathoner
who's been on the scene in track and
field and and long distance running for
a long time she had never won a major
marathon she's been to two Olympics in
the marathon but she still had yet to
win a big marathon and her goal had
always been to win Boston and every year
she'd go and she'd go and she'd never
wins she got close she got second one
year by just a hair
but she kept at it she kept showing up
and this past spring in April she was
able to win that race
finally after I don't know how many
attempts we can learn that there is
value in setting big goals and no matter
what the obstacles are that you face on
a daily basis and no matter how many
times you get kicked down how many times
it's two steps back for every step
forward that you just keep showing up
and keep showing up and keep showing up
how do you know that you're supposed to
do an Ironman how do you know that
you're supposed to be a millionaire I
think a lot of people are setting those
goals reactively without that kind of
internal inquiry that's required to
figure out what is the right or best
goal for you can you show up when
everything is stacked against you can
you show up when you don't feel like
showing up and that's kind of what today
is about like like back to Europe I mean
it's fun it's exciting this is what I do
for a living which is shocking and
unbelievable because I would do it for
free
but it's time away from my family there
is sacrifice involved and I'm devoted to
spreading this message of health and
vitality and sobriety and
and personal expression I have an
opportunity to do that so I'm showing up
for it just keep showing up
[Music]
all right peace brother thanks buddy